انا اليوم تكلمت مع احد مسؤولين الامم
المتحده وقلت لهم ما هي الاسباب قالوا هي
تعود لاسباب بيروقراطيه فقلت لهم سابقا
قلنا لكم بان
البيروقراطيه هي يعني تميت الاعمال ولكن
بيروقراطيه الامم المتحده اليوم هي ساهمت
بقتل الشعب السوري لانهم يحتاجون الى
موافقه من مجلس الامن حتى يستخدمون معابر
اخرى وهذا امر حقيقه يعني عار على الامم
المتحده ويجب عليها ان تعتذر للشعب السوري
وهذا ما سنطالب به في المستقبل
هل هناك توقعات ارتفاع خلال ساعه الطبيعه
وكم من الممكن ان يكون ان تكون امام
الرقايه بشباب حقيقه سيرتفع اعداد الضحايا
في الساعات القادمه لانه مع مرور الوقت
سيتم انتشار العديد من الضحايا لا نستطيع
اصدار تقدير نهائي قبل ان ننتهي من كافه
عمليات البحث والانقاذ عندما ننتهي سنصدر
التقرير النهائي وثناء عن الارقام
النهائيه التي انتشرناها من الجرحى
والمصابين ومن الضحايا الذين فقدوا حياتهم
بهذا الوقت فقط نستطيع ان نحدد الرقم
النهائي